[Music]
hi i'm chef branori
hi i'm chair from gaza tip today we're
going to show you how to make thai green
curry with chicken this thai eggplant is
crunchier than the purple eggplant it's
the traditional to use the green one
thai eggplant is seasonal for spring and
summer time usually in thailand we slice
it like this if we use chicken breast
but the authentic one usually we use the
whole chicken with the bone
these are the ingredients to make green
curry place
to start a place
i'm gonna toast the seeds
i start cooking since maybe 12. i
learned from my dad and my mom because
my dad and my mom
is a chef i love to make my own curry
because it's more tasty and i like it
fresh
and the smell is very good
if you cannot find the first ingredient
or you don't want to make it
you can fry the green chili paste at
thai market or the local grocery
if you make the green curry you're gonna
choose oily green chili if you make the
red curry i put the red chili
in thailand green curry is more popular
if it's not spicy it's not curry
[Music]
green curry place is a lot of work
normally i make just one time and a lot
you can take a little bit for make the
curry and if you have some left you can
keep it in refrigerator and can make
another dish next time
[Music]
the traditional curry we don't add basil
oil so the color is lighter my recipe we
use basil oil to make the curry look
more green in the past thai people when
they cook the curry they just use the
chili paste and water but then 100 years
later they start using coconut milk to
make a curry so
i think that time when the green curry
starts coconut milk it can make curry
more creamy and richer in the flavor and
sweeter so it has more more flavorful
than using water we are from phuket the
southern part of thailand and it is our
dream that to open a restaurant thai
restaurant in usa right now we have love
to eat restaurant and in total we have
three restaurants in los angeles thai
culture we're sitting together and we
eat together we have all the dish in the
middle of the table and we share all the
food that we eat with rice it's
different part from thailand like hanjai
fried chicken is from the southern part
papaya salad is from northeast of
thailand green curry is from santo so
it's kind of mix everything together
oh yes
[Music]
you